[موسيقى]
شهير عمل لي تلفون قال لي يا بيي خيي هو
تحت الجسم لا تقول قلت له اختك هيك ما
تقول قال والله يا بيي انا حملت حالي جاي
خيي وام بنته يعني انتم تاكدتوا منه انهم
رحلوا
توفوا ومعهد ما نقدر نشيلهم ما حد ما يقرب
لكن انت بدك جثامينهم تنتظر جتامين
الكاميرا اشرح لنا وين المبنى اللي هم
موجودين فيه
والله انا بنتي يوم الحد العصر الاحد عملت
لي التلفون يا جدي يا ددا ايش تعمل قلت
لها انا كثير كيس انت ايش قال يا جدي انا
يوم فلان الي ميلاد بيوم الخلق عيد
ميلادها عيد ميلاد بدك تجيني قلت بدي
اجيكي اما بدي يجيكي بشغله ايش قال يا
دادا ايش يا جدي شو هالشغله قلت لها ما
بقول لك هي بدي فريق هي بيوم البلادك
من تحت الجسم والغطه
ايش بدي اعمل انا امر نعزيكم نعزيكم بما
رحم يعني
الله يوفقكم الله يديمكم